welcome to this video step by step yeah
i need to change Milania in the NIMS oh
I have played the Zurich variation
against him a couple of times and I
really have to refresh my knowledge that
I got into big trouble so I'm going to
do something else here III that's a very
restrained way to play it not bad just a
bit unassuming ok looks a little bit
like the route goes on maybe I should
have taken here first actually but ok
that's not that's not not bad here check
just pretty normal for this for this
kind of opening it's a it's not there
probably not theoretically known
position but then the idea is the ideas
are pretty standard I want to go night
you for one later let's see if I get
this in okay well here well he cannot if
I go b5 he is going to go a 4 can i play
97 know is this too shaky I don't know
let's try that he cannot take on c4
because of rook c8 that's not that's not
only but other other things might be an
interesting interesting position
an interesting point is that sometimes I
have 90 form like here now here I can
play 94 theoretically speaking not sure
if it's good but it's it's an idea I can
also play what about a six then he's got
a form so don't want dad let's insert
this one he doesn't want to trade anyway
okay he will just want to trade yeah I
never guess any of his moves anyway I
know that from experience it's kind of
strange always feel like he's playing we
had moves but he somehow beating me most
of the time sometimes this happens you
sort of not get what one player is doing
and steady is beating you all the time
okay so a 50 Bishop g5 okay let's let's
play this np7 looks very risky c3 now is
probably not leading to much okay 64
would be six minute
yes III is not not a useful move can I
do this for Queen before may be tricky
position Luke p1 a half Knight c3 isn't
this good I don't know it is always
playing super quick moves that I don't
understand but mostly has mentioned it
it works out very well fun let's see
this should be good though right what is
he doing now you really don't see a play
we'll move him okay so he's he has to
had to give up the exchange c3 now yeah
let's push that an oopsie 84 c to f 60
is this a bad idea i'm pushing the night
away
it was not working unfortunately
i mean i can't play that move it since
it's this is just check it's not leading
to anything night g6 okay here I thought
c2 would be quite good see to take
stakes I a come on let's not
second-guess everything just because
this guy is beating me usually if it's
good it's good you should see to Quincy
for check I didn't see them I really I
really have huge issues to play against
the sky I don't know why I didn't I see
this move don't understand it yeah we
are it's really weird
check yeah it's not easy that's not an
easy that's not so easy this is position
he's hanging on it he's got more time
unbelievable I again managed to do
something entirely unnecessary and
stupid really amazing time morning hey I
is just pushing stuff is very easy to
play here this position
try for some kind of counter play it's
really that bad already check check
check check really hate this they play
really really bad and you don't punish
them check what did i do there with this
this is c2 pistachio unbelievable check
Oh last hope here they pour chaque nice
got various ways to win actually check
check not just one way check and you
probably will find one of them chatters
one check yeah come on I don't know what
it is the ants this guy how is loose I
can do what I want even even a totally
winning position I can't I lose Jeff and
here just just this is just over but I
managed to screw it up so this is Bishop
c4 or whatever I mean I simply I simply
didn't didn't see Bishop d3 just just
like that okay I don't know just it's
just very stupidly played yeah any move
wins he's playing that I know that it's
a usual scenario against you yeah this
is this is bad I'm not doing this dad
and over it's it's just it's just a
total inning and instead of c2 I can
also i can just play this this is this
is even much easier there's no need to
give up the sea porn at all so yeah okay
next next time I have to get him I don't
really know what that's putting our
Museum check it's it's just a complete
win okay Oh next time thanks for
watching